president trump is fiercely denying a
published report alleging that he
disparaged veterans for their military
service in the harshest of terms
calling those who died in combat quote
losers and suckers
the comments appear to overshadow the
upbeat august jobs report the labor
department released on friday
1.4 million jobs were added last month
it knocked down the nation's
unemployment rate to 8.4 percent
both the imam is at the white house this
morning with more on all of this
good morning good morning jeff white
house officials
are vocalizing their defense of the
president including melania trump
who rarely comments about her husband
and the president himself
lashed out at the atlantic calling the
story a hoax
there is nobody that feels more strongly
about our soldiers
our wounded warriors are soldiers that
died in war
than i do in a late afternoon press
briefing
president trump called the article in
the atlantic magazine part of an
ongoing witch-hunt against him it's a
hoax
just like the fake dossier was a hoax
just like the russia russia russia was a
hoax it was a total hoax
earlier in the day mr trump adamantly
denied claims in the piece
that he called soldiers killed in action
losers and
suckers when he canceled a visit to an
american world war one cemetery near
paris
in 2018. it was a terrible thing that
somebody could say the kind of things
and
especially to me because i've done more
for the military
than almost anybody else the article
also
claims that when former pow and senator
john mccain died two years ago
president trump told senior staffers
were not going to support that loser's
funeral
mr trump insisted he never called mccain
a loser
but he has a long history of criticizing
him he's a war hero because he was
captured
i like people that weren't captured okay
yesterday the president was asked
if he regretted those remarks i say what
i say
and i never got along with john mccain i
disagreed with john mccain on a lot of
things
that doesn't mean i don't respect him i
respected him my son matthew
is not a loser gold star families
responded to the atlantic article
in a new ad and retired major general
paul eaton posted this
direct message you're no patriot
let me tell you about a patriot my
father
was killed in vietnam
now the president also said that he
lowered the flags for the late senator
john mccain without hesitation
but former homeland security staffer
miles taylor said this was not true
and that the president was angry that
dhs
notified federal buildings to do so jeff
all right both
from the white house thank you very much